Yves, über 40 % der Ehen
in der Schweiz werden geschieden.
Warum bist du trotzdem verheiratet?
Das ist eine fiese Frage.
Das frage ich mich manchmal auch.
- Wirklich?
- Nein. Spass beiseite.
Es ist ein einfacher Grund:
Es ist Liebe.
Das ist total irrational.
Du weisst nicht, was kommt.
Jeder Mensch
ist im Grunde irrational.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Bei mir ist es so:
Vor der Einsamkeit,
der Zumutung, dass wir
alleine auf dieser Kugel sind,
brauche ich Schutz.
Du hast also
aus egoistischen Gründen geheiratet.
Erich Fromm hat es so gesagt:
Das Grundproblem
der menschlichen Existenz
ist das Alleinsein,
das Getrenntsein von etwas.
Die Liebe
gibt mir diese Geborgenheit.
Man hofft irgendwie,
dass Ehe und Liebe zusammengeht.
Aber es gibt auch Gründe
für die Ehe ohne Liebe.
- Umgekehrt kann man sich lieben,
ohne zu heiraten. - Ja.
Früher war der Grund für die Ehe
ein ökonomischer.
Sie brauchte ökonomische Sicherheit.
Und er wollte Nachwuchs.
Heute gibt es
dieses romantische Modell.
Der Philosoph Alain de Botton sagt,
wir leiden alle unter Romantizismus,
weil wir glauben,
für die Ehe spreche nur die Liebe.
Und wir glauben, die Liebe müsse vom
Anfang bis zum Tod dauernd lodern.
- Aber so ist es nicht.
- Nicht nur.
Es kann auch
eine Zweckgemeinschaft sein.
Vieles fällt im Leben einfacher,
wenn man jemanden an der Seite hat.
Klar, das geht auch mit Freunden.
Oder friends with benefits.
Aber da kommt bei mir das
romantische Liebesideal ins Spiel.
Dann muss man sich
nicht dauernd versichern,
ob der andere noch da ist.
Man hat einander ein Stück weit
einfach. Das entlastet.
Unromantisch, nicht?
Nein.
Das kann ich gut nachvollziehen.
Gerade in der heutigen Zeit,
wo der Liebesmarkt so funktioniert -
mit Tinder und Parship und so.
Eva Illouz,
eine israelische Soziologin, sagt,
eine feste Paarbeziehung
sei sozusagen
der ultimative Protestschrei
gegen den Kapitalismus
in den privaten Beziehungen.
Denn im Grunde genommen
haben wir durch den
dauernden Partnerwechsel begonnen,
unsere romantischen Verhältnisse
kapitalistisch zu durchtränken.
Man sucht immer
den noch besseren Treffer.
Man ist immer auf dem Absprung
und schaut,
wo es noch interessanter
und einfacher wäre.
Damit ist man immer
zur Disposition gestellt.
Das ist wie einer, der
seit zehn Jahren dasselbe Handy hat.
- Oder dasselbe T-Shirt?
- Was?
Der Kapitalismus treibt uns an,
immer das Neuere zu haben.
- Und das Bessere.
- Ja.
Derjenige, der seit 20 Jahren
dasselbe Hemd trägt,
schadet dem Wirtschaftswachstum.
Wenn alle so wären, würde
unsere Gesellschaft anders aussehen.
Das meine ich. Das ist der Protest.
Man spricht auch von Treue.
Nicht nur in Liebesverhältnissen.
Man sagt auch:
"Ich bin meiner Schuhmarke treu."
Viele Menschen
geben als Begründung nicht nur an,
es seien die besten Schuhe,
sondern sie denken auch,
es sei entlastend, nicht immer
neue Schuhe suchen zu müssen.
Dann muss man sich eine Frage
nicht mehr stellen.
Schon etwas kränkend für
deinen Mann, wenn er quasi ...
- Ein Schuh?
- ... eine Entlastung ...
"Du sorgst für Entlastung
in meinem Leben."
"Du machst es einfacher."
"Du bist zwar nicht der Beste,
vielleicht auch nicht der Richtige,
aber du entspannst mich."
Das klingt extrem negativ.
Man kann es positiv sagen.
"Ich habe das Vertrauen,
dass wir es gut zusammen haben."
"Ich weiss auch,
wenn ich realistisch bin,
dass es gute
und schlechte Zeiten gibt."
Das sagt man
im Eheversprechen auch so.
"Trotzdem lasse ich mich darauf ein
und bin bereit,
mich nicht mehr umzuschauen."
Angenommen, deine Gefühle
für deinen Mann sind weg.
Du hast dieses Versprechen gegeben.
Doch dann fühlt sich
die Form der Ehe wie ein Korsett an.
Dann ist es nicht mehr schön.
Und wenn es wirklich zerstörerisch
wird, hat man heute die Möglichkeit,
sich zu trennen -
das ist auch richtig so.
Aber man sollte sich nicht
bei jeder Krise fragen,
ob es jemanden Besseres gibt.
Das hat der französische Philosoph
Alain Badiou
im Gespräch mit dir gesagt:
- Man müsse daran arbeiten.
- "Die Bühne der zwei", sagt er.
Auf der Bühne der zwei
gibt es eine neue Möblierung.
Es gibt eine neue Szenerie.
Neues entsteht.
Das braucht Mut.
Man muss etwas von sich aufgeben.
Es braucht Kompromissfähigkeit.
Aber es entsteht eine neue Bühne,
ein neues Stück.
- Man kann eine neue Geschichte
von sich schreiben. - Ja.
Der amerikanische Philosoph
Robert Nozick sagt,
zwei Biografien
verschmelzen im Idealfall zu einer.
Es gibt ein erweitertes Ich.
Und er hat gefragt:
Wie begründen wir, dass das
der richtige Partner für mich ist?
Das ist sehr schwierig. Vielleicht
sucht man nach Eigenschaften.
Und da hat man das Problem,
dass es viele andere gibt,
die diese Eigenschaften auch haben -
vielleicht sogar noch besser sind.
Da fragt man sich:
Warum wechselt man nicht?
"Wer die Antwort geben kann,
liebt noch nicht wirklich",
hat Robert Spaemann gesagt.
- Interessant ist doch:
Lange Liebe
hat immer wieder damit zu tun,
wieder zu lernen, neu zu schauen.
Das habe ich im Gespräch
mit Alain de Botton gelernt.
Er hat ein eigenartiges Bild
in seinem Buch.
Er beschreibt
das Spargelbild von Édouard Manet.
Auf die Art und Weise wie er
die Spargeln beim Malen des Bildes
neu gesehen hat, muss man
den Partner oder der Partnerin
in einer Krise
immer wieder neu sehen -
auch die Ecken und Kanten.
Das klingt in meinen Ohren
auch wieder sehr romantisch.
Es kann passieren,
dass die Gefühl irgendwann weggehen.
Die Ecken und Kanten,
die man vorher geliebt hat,
sind plötzlich abstossend.
Hoffentlich passiert uns das nicht.
Was tut man
in einer solchen Situation?
Was war dieses Versprechen?
"Ich möchte dich
bis ans Lebensende lieben."
Gefühle
kann man nicht kontrollieren.
Aber man kann sie
vielleicht kultivieren.
- Genau.
- Man kann sie pflegen.
Es ist sehr interessant,
was das konkret heisst.
Das ist ein wichtiges Stichwort.
Kultivieren
ist ein wichtiges Stichwort.
Wer sich ewige Liebe verspricht,
hat wirklich ...
Alain de Botton
spricht von romantischer Verblödung.
Das ist hart.
Aber ein Gefühl
kann man sich nicht versprechen.
Aber man kann sich versprechen,
daran zu arbeiten.
Vielleicht meinen die mit Liebe
genau das -
ewige Umsorgung, ewiger Versuch usw.
Genau.
Das ist realistischer als zu sagen:
"Ich verspreche dir,
dass meine Flamme für immer lodert."
Der Ehevertrag
ist per se ein Vertrag über Treue.
Für viele ist das so.
Das müsste aber nicht so sein.
Früher war es sogar umgekehrt:
Wer nicht verheiratet war, durfte
keine sexuellen Liebschaften pflegen.
Ab dem 18. Jh.,
wenn man verheiratet war ...
... konnte man tun, wie man wollte.
Es war sogar erwartet, dass man
neben der Ehe Liebschaften hat.
- Von beiden Seiten?
- Ja.
Das kann man bei Guy de Maupassant
in der Erzählung "Jadis" nachlesen.
Beide haben ihre Liebschaften.
Das war auch erwartet und wichtig.
Sonst funktionierte die Ehe nicht.
Viele
empfinden das heute als Konflikt.
Einerseits die Geborgenheit,
Sicherheit, Zweisamkeit.
Das gilt für Menschen,
die nicht polyamor leben.
Andererseits
ist da ab und zu das Bedürfnis
oder die Neugier nach etwas anderem.
Um zurück auf den Markt zu kommen:
Es gibt da draussen viel,
das man verpasst.
Interessant ist doch, dass man heute
alle Möglichkeiten hat.
Man kann sich verlieben,
sich binden, sich wieder lösen,
keine Bindung eingehen.
- Es gibt die maximale Freiheit.
- Ja.
2018 wurde ein Studie
im amerikanischen Magazin
"The Atlantic" publiziert
mit dem Titel "The sex recession".
Dort wurde gesagt, dass die jungen
Amerikanerinnen und Amerikaner
noch nie so wenig Sex hatten
wie heute.
Die totale Freiheit führt
also offenbar nicht zu mehr Sex.
Vielleicht
ist es gar nicht so schlecht,
sich zu bescheiden und
in einer festen Beziehung zu leben.
Vielleicht ist es ein Trugschluss,
dass mehr laufe, wenn man freier ist.
- Das ist beruhigend.
- Nicht wahr?
Auf Freiheiten zu verzichten -
das ist ein gutes Stichwort.
Man sagt immer,
dass eine feste Beziehung heisst,
auf Freiheiten zu verzichten.
In der Philosophie gibt es
ganz andere Vorschläge, die besagen,
die Form von Liebe und Bindung
sei eine höhere Form von Freiheit.
Kant sagt über Freiheit ...
Autonomie
bedeutet Selbstgesetzgebung.
Man ist nicht dann frei,
wenn man macht, was einem passt.
Man ist frei, wenn man sich selbst
ein Gesetz, ein Prinzip gibt
und dieses verfolgt.
Das ist Freiheit.
Da bindet man sich auch.
Man gibt seinen Begierden
nicht einfach im Moment hin.
Man hält sich an das,
was einem wichtig im Leben ist.
Interessant an der Heirat ist,
dass aufgezeigt wird,
dass der Mensch
eine Gemeinschaft braucht.
Wenige heiraten einfach zu zweit mit
zwei Trauzeugen auf dem Standesamt.
Das ist ein schönes Bild.
Eine gelingende Paarbeziehung
ist oft eine Beziehung,
die in einem grösseren Ganzen
stattfindet.
Man stellt sich
in den Kontext einer Gemeinschaft.
Man steht zueinander vor einer Schar
von Zeuginnen und Zeugen.
Das hat eine symbolische Wirkung.
Diese symbolische Wirkung
einer Eheschliessung ist grossartig.
Man könnte dir vorwerfen, dass du
das Gesicht vor anderen verlierst,
weil du öffentlich geheiratet hast.
Zögert man deshalb
eine Scheidung heraus?
Das ist vielleicht
gar nicht so schlecht.
Da sind wir wieder bei der Frage
nach der Rolle, die man spielt.
- Für die anderen?
- Nein.
Man wahrt eine Form. In der Form
zu bleiben kann auch Halt geben.
Das ist nicht immer falsch, Yves.
Aber es ist keine Freiheit mehr,
wenn man es für die anderen macht.
Es heisst nicht,
dass ich es für die anderen mache.
Man kann auch einfach einsehen,
dass es Dinge gibt,
die einen ins Schleudern bringen. Und
da darf man sich ruhig festhalten.
Yves und ich finden uns
bei diesem Thema nicht ganz.
Warum sind Sie verheiratet? Schreiben
Sie es in die Kommentarspalte.
Mit Eva Illouz und Alain de Botton
habe ich über die lange Liebe
gesprochen - da drüben.